this is Entertainment Tonight hello
everyone and thanks for joining us
Samantha Harris here in for Nancy O'Dell
and there is big news to start the week
Richard Simmons held hostage he set the
record straight as fans Maurice Michelle
Turner had tonight's top story
where did Richard Simmons go there are
strong fears for the safety and
well-being of the star so what happened
to Richard Simmons well after a two-year
public absence the fitness guru broke
his silence and addressed all kinds of
rumors with et weight gain witchcraft
even kidnapping no I'm not kidnapped I'm
under no spell sometimes we get lost and
our sadness here's what had people
really concerned Richards last public
appearance was in January of 2014 he
attended a fundraiser for California's
health insurance exchange then in
January of last year the LAPD responded
to an anonymous tip and came here to
Richard's mansion in the Hollywood Hills
he was found to be alert and responsive
now our last sit-down with Richard was
in August of 2013 and this moment caught
our attention when the king gets
depressed he doesn't call for his wife
or the cook he calls for the little man
with pointed hat
and he says to the court jester maybe
and I am a court jester on Saturday in a
story called the haunted Twilight of
Richard Simmons the New York Daily News
cited a former friend who claimed
Richard is being tormented by witchcraft
under the control of his housekeeper
that appears to be the housekeeper
Theresa today at his house e t--'s
executive producer asked Richard about
her is she holding you hostage oh no
today sir
has been with me for 30 years she were
like an old married couple
when was the last time you actually left
her house
well I go it on rye then I go on walks
but you know I haven't done any
television lately
why still 150 I work out every day I
have a gym here at the house and I'm
very healthy there was time for me to
take some time to be by myself you know
for the last 40 years of traveling
teaching classes and I had a knee injury
so I had a knee replacement which was
very difficult for me and now my other
knee is hurting and I don't want to have
another replacement so I've just really
been taking it easy no one should be
worried about me